the search for sunlight is long and
winding quite literally in fact for the
cucumber plant as climbing plants they
make use of tendrils specialized thread
like extensions that swing around in
search of a structure to latch on to one
stared in place a tendril pulls the rest
of the plant up behind it historically
the study of plant tendrils have been
documented since the 18th century
notably Darwin described tendril coils
as a series of soft Springs since then
we have come a long way in describing
their anatomy and mechanics it is known
for instance that the suspended portion
of a tendril coils into a helical shape
with at least two oppositely handed
helix EES connected by a helical
perversion this helical coiling shortens
the tendril lengthwise hoisting the
plant toward the attachment point our
recent findings have determined even
more mechanical and mathematical
specifics of tendril coiling this
coiling is made possible by a stiff
ribbon like strip of specialized cells
within tendrils called the fibre ribbon
during coiling the fibre ribbon
contracts asymmetrically when the
tendril is ready to coil a chemical
compound called lignin accumulates in
the ventral side of the ribbon this
stiffens the ventral side shortening it
relative to the dorsal side an
artificial model of this process is
depicted here it unwinds and flattens as
it is pulled from both ends to create
the model start with an unstrained
silicone rubber strip and stretch it
axially apply a silicone caulk layer and
allow it to cure it represents the most
rudimentary of models emulating nature
just some
but not completely here is a natural
tendril acting in much the same way as
the previous model as it is extended it
unwinds to the point of flattening out
now here is a natural tendril over
winding as it is extended so what causes
this difference let's turn to a more
complicated model here we can observe a
silicon model that has been adjusted to
over wined instead of unwind upon
stretching this adjustment has been made
by adding a copper wire to the exterior
of its helix and a fabric ribbon to its
interior together the fabric ribbon and
wire increased the models effective
bending stiffness with respect to
twisting stiffness making the intrinsic
helix curvature harder to change while
still allowing the model to twist around
its center line in other words the model
is less able to flatten out and more
likely to add coils to compensate for
the force being exerted on it from both
ends
mathematically if the force needed to
bend the material is less than the force
required to twist it there is more
bending than twisting and so the tendril
unwinds on extension flattening out
young tendrils tend to unwind as they
are typically easier to bend than to
twist
in contrast old tendrils tend to be
harder to bend than to twist and they
over wind when pulled but what does over
winding mean for the plant pulling leads
to a two phase response by the tendril
first it acts like a soft spring while
over winding but then it enters a second
more resistant phase as it begins to
unwind this unusual type of spring with
a two phase mechanical response has
never been seen before in nature or in
engineering design our investigations of
humber tendrils provide insight into how
these plants reach a vital resource
sunlight and furthermore suggest a new
design for Springs that may prove useful
in engineering